welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka han solo and this video are breaking
down
episode 3 of star wars the bad batch the
series so far has had a roller coaster
ride throughout the galaxy
that's chronicled the rise of the empire
throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down all the
easter eggs in the new entry
the general story and we'll also be
giving our theories on what could be
coming around the corner
both spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the show
then you should force yourself out of
here if you enjoy the video then please
click the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the bad batch
episode 3.
now up top i've been getting nothing but
banthapuru for how i've been pronouncing
omega i've been trying to say it how
it's said in the show which is
omega but i just can't do it anymore
i've been saying amigo all the time
and i'm freeing myself of youtube's
control i will call her
omega from now on so brave hashtag
inspiration now speaking of standing up
for what you believe in
we've just watched the bad batch go on a
big arc throughout the show
that tackles themes like subservience
and freedom
after they deserted their unit they
travelled through space to meet la
quaine
a clone trooper who went awol after the
battle of genosis
the queen mentioned that he'd recently
encountered captain rex
and we also saw firsthand how the galaxy
was starting to be warped into a more
imperialistic system
the bad batch ended up going
head-to-head with their brothers once
more
and they managed to get cut and his
family off the planet they flew off into
episode 3
which is where we pick up with them
right
now now the episode is called
replacements and this carries a lot of
meaning to it
not only is the ship damaged and needs
some of its parts replaced
but the clone troopers are also slowly
being replaced by the empire's soldiers
throughout the episode we watch as
crosshairs is selected to train soldiers
for the imperials
in order to have the best of both worlds
as we learn in the original saga
the imperials realize that it's much
cheaper to take children from their
homes
and force them into their army and we're
really watching that mentality being set
up in this entry
we pick up with the ship traveling
through hyperspace and you might notice
early on that there are sparks flying
off the back of it which foreshadows the
damage going on internally
now you also might have noticed that the
voice over which is typical at the start
of the clone wars
is completely gone this appeared in the
first episode but it's been absent for
the last two
making me think that that was the final
usage of it it was parodying war
propaganda from the 1940s
and with it being missing i'm guessing
it cements that the war
is fully over captain obvious now tech
says
he's trying to make a scanner that tests
the abilities of their inhibitor chips
and i believe that once they know the
full extent of how they operate
that they'll be able to control them
this means that they'll also be able to
save crosshair
who is of course now under the empire's
control the ship goes into a steep
nosedive after being thrown out of
hyperspace
and the batch crash land on a moon i
love how whilst this is going on
we can see the gonk droid that rekka was
using as a dumbbell
sliding across the floor he and omega
end up strapping in
and during this crash landing there are
several lines pulled from the dropship
scene in aliens
and the design of the restraint looks
very similar too
upon landing we do get some more hints
that omega might be force sensitive
as she goes to crosshairs weapon kit
clearly there's a lot of emotion around
his departure
and it is possible that she could have
been drawn to it now it's also possible
that she just picked this box at random
but i love how the show is giving little
things to fan theorists like myself to
pick a part
i don't want to go or mephisto again
though so let me know if you disagree
now even though he leaves his shoulder
feeling like it's been hit with a
covered vaccine
the group definitely missed crosshair
and we cut to kamino to see him being
scanned
the bad batch were of course resistant
to the inhibitor chip
and thus we can assume that most humans
and aliens that aren't duplicates
would be too however cross hair could be
subjected to its influence
and admiral tolkien is desperate to know
if there's a way to completely control
all free will this would potentially
mean that everyone in the galaxy would
end up loyal to the empire
and the consequences of this experiment
are definitely chilling
it's here that we also meet vice admiral
rampart in the flesh for the first time
he did pop up in episode 2 and is going
to be one of the big baddies in the show
his chain code implementation has been
highly successful
and shout outs ryanairy from screencrush
for pointing out that
boba fett 2 talked about his in the
mandalorian this means that the act
has a long legacy with it now you might
also notice in the scene that the
imperials and cameron owens
referred across there by his designation
cc9904
this shows how they treat their soldiers
as products rather than people
and i love how the show is very much
about whether to conform or not
if you do then you will be treated as a
number amongst many
whereas those that rise up get to have
their own lives and personalities
talking in rampart discuss project war
mantle which
was first mentioned in the novelization
of rogue one in that we learned that
this initiative
was created by talking and that it had
been kept on scarif along with the death
star plans
crosshair will now head up the training
of the empire's brand new elite squad
made up of the best of the best of the
best sir little does he know though he's
training his replacement
and this is basically like yeah when
when your job hires a new guy
and gets you to show them the ropes be
careful with him yeah he's gonna replace
you one day and as we all know the
clones will be wiped out
in order to have these sort of soldiers
step in though they can't hit for [ __ ]
now on the moon tech changes the
capacitor on the ship with echo
in a scene that echoes the one in the
empire strikes back
they even use similar breathing
apparatus to what han had on
however instead of minox attaching
themselves to the hull
it's an auto moon dragon one of these
circulates the ship
and takes the capacitor for themselves
these monsters feed on raw energy
and i might just be jumping at shadows
but i'm sure that echo moves his
flashlight over one for a brief second
i'm recording this before editing the
video so if i've left this bit in
then i'm right but if i didn't i'll take
it out and you'll never know how much of
an
idiot i am what you mean you already
knew anyway i got a lot more alien vibes
from this moon
as it highly resembles the state of
lv426
in that film hunter shows how much
better of a parent that he is now
by letting omega come along to hunt the
dragon and we watch his wrecker
complaints about how much his head hurts
this could be setting up future events
and potentially the chip inside may have
been shifted
and it is possible that the empire could
end up controlling him
whilst we don't know that for definite
they do bring a lot of attention to it
but it may just be an excuse for him to
remain behind on the ship
on kamino we see the new recruits
discussing how loyal they are to the
empire now
and i've often wondered about why
soldiers who fought for the republic
so happily joined up with them we
discover that the empire pays
and houses them for better however we
know that the republic pretty much ended
up becoming the empire after palpatine
took it over
and with him being the chancellor he
likely caused those poor conditions
tarkin sends the troopers to under on
which we of course saw in episode one
when we met saw i swear that's not a pun
but
i'm so used to doing them i i don't even
know anymore now the camera owens
are clearly being pushed out at this
point and now they argue that the clones
are much more efficient than the
enlisted soldier will ever be
head office need to save money the
elites really don't respect the clones
and the empire has of course used hate
to make people fall in line with their
ways firstly they made the galaxy hate
the jedi
by stating they tried to assassinate the
chancellor this enabled the genocide
that was carried out on them
next they made the clones hate each
other who were slightly different to
them
and now they're making regular people
hate the clones so they will strive to
take the opportunity to be in the army
from them
it's very well constructed storytelling
that carries a lot of political
commentary with it
about how things are manipulated by
governments so that people turn on one
another
instead of those in charge we find that
the rebels are evacuating
and that saw has already moved on
crosses crews stormed the camp
and though they succeed in their mission
we know that the bad batch are much
happier having chosen a path in which
they allowed them to live one of the
rebels refuses to give up saw
and crosshair shoots them and says i
believe you
might just be my batman brain kicking in
here but this could be a nod to the dark
knight returns
in which a similar scene happened this
also appeared in batman v superman
but let me know below if you disagree
now we see unlike crosshair
one of the soldiers questions the orders
and he refuses to just murder civilians
crosshair kills him showing that
defiance will no longer be tolerated
and it does cement how much his
programming has warped him as a person
when we follow things blindly we are
truly lost
and it's going to be interesting to see
if they can redeem crosshair or not
i would love it if it turned out that
his chip wasn't actually really working
much like the bad batch and that he was
actually just more willing to commit war
crimes
because he's a bad lad that would be a
great twist i think but whether they do
that or not
yeah i don't know but just just to know
that he's just a bad person deep down i
think would be a great surprise
now hunter and omega find the moon
dragon but the former's mask is removed
and because of the atmosphere on the
planet
he falls unconscious omega takes things
into her own hands
and goes after the beast to herself
which leads her down cavinus tunnels
here we see the monster isn't all that
bad and instead of shooting it
she simply distracts it with a
flashlight because it likes to feed on
energy it doesn't matter where the
source comes from
and thus she's able to retrieve the
capacitor crosshair returns home
and talking views the soldiers as
following orders blindly
even though we know that they had to be
given a life or death ultimatum in order
to do it
many soldiers throughout the saga would
have caused effect
and this leads to the rebellion growing
in numbers therefore
talking short-sightedness and
willingness to just save money
does cost him a lot little pun there now
the coming owens are starting to feel
like blockbuster
after netflix showed up and they decide
that in order to stay
making that dough they need to up their
product this further ties back to the
theory that they will try and replicate
a force sensitive being
which we know from the latter part of
the saga does come to pass
even if it's the empire heading it up
crosshair clearly misses his brothers
much like how they miss him and back on
the ship wrecker has made a bedroom for
omega
she's now part of the hashtag squad and
we end the episode with her
finally having found a place to call
home
now as for my thoughts on the series so
far i have to say i'm really enjoying
the way that they're tackling the themes
of the show
almost every character in it has to
wrestle with either sticking to their
orders
or going off to carve out their own path
it's a mature take on war
and no animated shows a lot of
psychology behind being a soldier
these clones are starting to question
what they're really fighting for
if they should still follow the rules
and it's created a divide amongst their
ranks that makes for a really
interesting show
it's very much debating whether you
should conform to have an easier life
or if you should stand up for what you
think is right and it is subject matter
that has been and will always be
relevant
that's why i love the show it's taking
one of the darkest times in star wars
lore
and showing how things played out
through the eyes of a family of soldiers
left wondering what their purpose is now
that there's no one left to fight
i also love omega and i feel like when
this is all over she's gonna be the big
character to come out of it
there's even theories that she might be
ray's mother who at this point we know
very little about
but i kind of hope that doesn't turn out
to be true as i think there's way more
that they can do with her in her
training
either way great episode and thank you
as always for joining me on another
breakdown
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus con collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so you know i give away these prizes
yeah and if that's you then message me
on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the venom let there be carnage trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over all the easter eggs in it
and pointed out some of the things that
you probably missed
yes you so go and check it out cheers
goodbye